you already been sipping there uh yes
why not okay the game's called sipper
spiel so basically if you don't answer
the question well you got to take a sip
okay that tequila there mark and kevin
actually brought their own tequila
brands along which left regina caught in
the middle
let's get to it let's go regina you're
first step young lady oh all right super
spill who do you think wins in the gym
between these two
gym rats
that's a tough question yeah that's a
tough one
well take a sip well who do i sip i
think that you should start off with
mark because i'm a gentleman i would
love for you to go with mark first and
he's older
oh nice it's nice
very smooth zipper spill mark what do
you kids think about the marky mark
fashion that you were rocking back in
the 90s yeah i'll step in so they're
terribly embarrassed by it but my son
the whole time we're on summer break
doesn't have a shirt and his underwear
totally stole the whole look got the
next question for you kevin so sipper
spill we get some musical moments from
you in the film so what's your go-to
like
jam that you love to just sing out to in
the car i want to sit we get an option
y'all we're gonna have to carry mr heart
out of here
i know it i know it i know it all over
the
wall no stop it that was a bit you guys
know i would never do that whatever
tequila's great i'm a big belieber
um and i'm sorry i can't believe it it's
one of my favorite songs oh give us a
rendition i'm sorry
okay next time we are definitely doing
karaoke but for now the trio wanted to
talk about their new movie me time out
on netflix august 26th kevin plays a
stay-at-home dad who reluctantly goes to
unwind at his pal's wild birthday party
i told you you could do it i love you
huh
what did folks need to know before they
go to see this movie to be honest with
you uh this movie is a good time yeah i
couldn't ask for a better cast to work
with
oh sit down
i watched it with my my whole family and
people that didn't know anything about
the story of the script and to see the
kids be able to enjoy it as much as the
adults there's a lot of humor that goes
a little bit over their heads um but
yeah very very enjoyable oh
[Music]